and here it is it is called fallout
shelter and in it you get to make your
own vault and you are the overseer
controlling everything you control the
people in the vault it's your job to
keep them productive and happy this is
inspired by games the other games we
love going back 30 years to little
computer people you'll see inspirations
obviously from XCOM SimCity FTL things
that we really really like each dweller
has full stats they all level up
there are items you can give them new
outfits weapons which they'll need when
you send them off into the wasteland so
they'll head off in the wasteland and
they'll have adventures and get stuff
this is actually inspired by an odd
little RPG called progress quests if
you've never looked look it up as really
cute a resources are important having
the right balance of food water and
power
there are lots of different rooms you
can build ones that give you resources
some of them train people they train
your dwellers that's the bar of course
trains charisma classroom does
intelligence there are children more on
that in a bit you do get rewarded with
lunch boxes full of random loot
accidents can happen fires can break out
rat Rocha taxes attacks Raiders can
attack of course the the best way to get
new dwellers is the old the
old-fashioned way
that raises their happiness when they go
in the room of course is overseer you
get the name all the babies um and that
is fallout shelter
you